JENNA TAYLOR: My
name's Jenna Taylor.
I'm the newest member
of the Google Food team,
here in Mountain View.
And I'm delighted to be your
facilitator for today's talk
at Google.
We're very lucky to be joined
this afternoon by James Beard
award winner for Best Chef
California, San Francisco
magazine's chef of the
year, chef Michael Mina.
As many of you guys
know, Chef Mina
is founder of the Mina Group,
a restaurant management
company operating 26
restaurants around the country.
And joining Chef Mina today
is Mina Group president,
Patric Yumul.
Mr. Yumul started working
with Chef Mina in 1999,
and has since helped
grow the brand
from four restaurants to 26.
Clearly, it's a
magical partnership.
Thank you both so much
for being with us today.
I know I have some
questions, based
on my having followed your
career and your Instagram,
frankly, for some time.
And then, we would love
to open it up to questions
from the audience, as well.
All right, sound good?
MICHAEL MINA: Great, great.
JENNA TAYLOR: So you've always
got something new going on.
You guys have all these
restaurants and concepts.
Maybe tell us a little bit
about your newest project.
MICHAEL MINA: Sure.
Well, our newest
project-- last year
we did-- last year we opened
nine restaurants in a ten month
period.
And they were fairly
significant restaurants,
and not just restaurants.
We actually did a market
in St. Petersburg.
And so this year, our focus was
to really launch this-- what
we were calling a test kitchen.
But we wanted to take a
much different approach
with the test kitchen.
We didn't really
want to just create
a place to go and test recipes,
and create dishes, and then put
them in restaurants.
We wanted the test kitchen to
serve a few different purposes.
And really, the first purpose
was not just to test dishes.
We wanted to get a
lot more out of it,
which was test concepts--
test the complete concept.
Be able to take
a concept, do it.
And in this day and age, with
the way pop-ups have gone,
and the ability
to say, OK, today,
this restaurant is going
to be this concept.
So we know we found a perfect
scenario, in the sense that it
was a neighborhood restaurant.
We really felt-- a
lot of our restaurants
are large restaurants.
And they're usually
in major cities.
A lot, obviously, here in
the Bay Area-- it's our home.
But we wanted this to
be in a neighborhood,
so we found a
restaurant space that
was already built out
in a little building
that we could buy.
And we created what we're
calling the Mina Test Kitchen.
And it's just going to
continually change concepts.
And it's on Greenwich Fillmore.
So it's kind of right
down in Cow Hollow
neighborhood, close to
where Patrick lives.
And it's like 45 seats, and
it has a great little kitchen
in it.
And so we're doing a
concept, naming the concept,
and running it for three months.
The first concept is
called middle terranian,
and so it's Mediterranean
and the Middle East.
And I was born in Egypt,
and so it's-- and my chef,
corporate chef, who's kind
of our partner in this whole
thing, he has a lot
of Israeli background.
And so what we're
doing is really
creating this first concept.
It's a pop-up, and
what we'll do is
we'll run it for three months.
We run it four nights a
week, and get real feedback.
And then, three
months later, we'll
kind of redecorate a little,
and launch another concept.
On the other days, that
we're not running it,
those are days that
we'll be testing dishes
for the other restaurants.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's exciting.
Innovation-- kind of pushing
the envelope with a new idea.
That's certainly
something that resonates,
I think, with Googlers.
MICHAEL MINA: Yeah, it's
kind of interesting,
because when you
really think about it,
it's something that could never
have been done 10 years ago.
Because without all
of the everything
that's out there, the ways to
communicate what you're doing.
We were laughing about
it the other day,
because what you're saying,
like with Instagram,
and Facebook, and Twitter,
and all the different avenues
you have now to
get the word out,
you could have
never done something
like this 10 years
ago, as a restaurateur.
Because really, the only way you
were going to get a message out
to somebody was that
traditional PR--
go out, PR a restaurant
for a year, open it up.
And then the only
photos anybody's
ever going to see is when you
reviewed, or-- and now, it's
just obviously instantaneous,
what you can do,
and how you can message what
you're doing by the minute, as
opposed to really not
having-- really giving
people access to what you're
doing, what you're changing.
So for us, it's going to be
fun, because each week we
can create new dishes.
And then ultimately, the
goal is, within three months,
to have a complete menu to take
that restaurant, if we like it,
and then go open
it someplace else.
JENNA TAYLOR: And then
you have a little bit
of a fan base built in, so
you're getting a head start
on opening up a real concept.
Yeah, that's exciting.
That's very exciting.
So that's one thing
that I find fascinating
about your guys'
company and partnership,
is that the way
you've found success--
with so many different concepts
in different locations.
Will you talk to us a
little bit about what
are those core threads,
that bind amongst all
of your restaurants?
Why do you think
they're all successful?
PATRIC YUMUL: I think,
although there's
a lot of different restaurants,
it's really-- it's one thing.
It's understanding
culture through food.
And for us, we love to
discover, we love to explore,
we love to travel.
We love to connect to
people, to societies,
to the civilizations.
And so, we love to
kind of go to Japan,
and understand the
history of Japan,
and understand how
society works in Japan,
by going to different
restaurants and eating.
It's the one common
thread that exists
throughout every culture,
throughout every society.
Everybody has to
sustain themselves.
nourish themselves.
They have to eat, they
have to come together,
whether it's independently
or as a family.
And so we're really obsessed
with understanding that.
And then learning
about it, and then
sharing those
learnings with people.
And it allows us to
have connections.
And I think as humans, and as
husbands and fathers and wives
and sisters and brothers, we all
want to connect to each other.
We all want to feel like
we belong to something.
And for us, it's telling
the story of food
that allows us to connect to
our guests, to our employees,
to our heritage, our roots.
With middle terrania,
that's allowing Michael,
for the first time ever,
to connect back to the way
he ate every night
when he was growing up.
And he kind of had to go a
long way to do it, right?
He went and studied French
cuisine, and modern cuisine,
and expressed himself in
a lot of different ways
throughout the years.
But now it's kind going back to
a very rudimentary beginning.
I think it's going
to be very special.
JENNA TAYLOR: So we talk
about this instantaneous
gratification of
technology, and we
talk about these old traditions
of coming together over food.
So how do you, as
restaurateurs and chefs,
find that balance between
technology and tradition,
and the ways that
those can interplay?
MICHAEL MINA: Well, I mean, I
think that with technology, you
look at it obviously--
probably, I would say,
three different categories.
You look at the first one, which
is always the most important
to us, is, how is
anything going to help
us connect with our guests?
I mean, you asked
about our philosophies,
or what's been kind
of the underlying
thread of our restaurants,
throughout all
of our restaurants.
The one thing that we-- the
first restaurant I ever did
was called Aqua and it
was in San Francisco,
on California Street.
And I'd been in New York,
I'd been working in New York.
But I was a west coast person.
I was more-- my mindset was
a little more west coast
than east coast.
And--
PATRIC YUMUL: You grew up on
a [INAUDIBLE], Ellensburg,
Washington, so.
MICHAEL MINA: Yeah.
And I always said that
we want the same level
of food, the same
level of service
that you get in New York.
And this was back in '89.
We opened in '91.
I said, but with kind of the
friendliness of California--
the mindset of California.
And the goal was always,
how do you-- we look at it,
and we say, how do
you befriend people?
How do you build long term
relationships with people?
Because that's what
it's all about.
I mean, all of it, at the
end of the day-- there's
going to be great chefs.
There's going to be
many more great chefs.
For me, I've always--
I said from day one,
I'll never build
a whisper joint.
And whisper joint, to me, is a
restaurant where you go into.
And it could be
just spectacular.
It could be the best food.
It could be the best
showcase for me to cook,
but where people feel
like they need to whisper,
and they feel like that.
And there's nothing wrong
with those restaurants,
it's just not my personality.
So I said from day one,
that's not what I want.
And so Aqua was a
140 seat restaurant,
trying to do four
star food, four star
service with a big, loud bar.
And really, the city
had never seen anything
like that at the time, it was
really a different mindset.
And so, there was going to
always be bumps in the road.
So you really had to
befriend your customers,
so that you could kind of
understand that energy.
When you build
something where it's
so precious, when one
little thing goes wrong,
all of a sudden, really,
it goes from being
a very insignificant problem,
to a more significant problem.
When you create a
certain environment
of just really hospitality
and relaxation, but very high
level food, very
high level service,
I think that it gives
you that ability
to get people to be part of
what you're doing for a much
longer period of time.
It's more accessible.
People want to be relaxed.
And so technology, in that
sense, with our guests,
has helped us tremendously.
And Patrick can probably
talk about it more than me,
but we were the first ones--
when Open Table started,
we were one of the
original three restaurants,
where they took
our-- from Aqua, they
took our reservation papers,
and we explained to them
how it all worked.
And we were part of that,
from the very beginning.
And seeing that as just
kind of that very first step
of technology, of how,
now all of a sudden,
we actually had
information on our guests.
It wasn't just--
we always had it,
but it was always hand written,
you know, after they left.
But when you cook a
meal for somebody,
this is how my first
introduction to technology was.
Mr. Johnson comes in, I cook
him a nine course menu, right?
He leaves, I have to
write it all down.
The next time he
comes in, I gotta
remember everything
that I cooked for him,
so I can cook him
a different menu.
And really, technology-- my
very first encounter with it was
just kind of being able to
house everybody's-- what we are
cooking, what people's
allergies were.
What people's likes and
dislikes, what their wine
preferences were-- all of
these things that just make you
be able to make your
guest feel much more
appreciated when they
come into your restaurant.
That was kind of my
first experience with it.
And now, it's unbelievable
what you can do.
I mean, you can probably talk
a little bit more about that.
PATRIC YUMUL: Right.
I mean, our philosophy is
tech shouldn't replace touch.
And we want to use
technology as a tool,
in order to have better
experiences for not
just our guests, but
for our employees,
and for everybody
that's working for us.
So we've developed platforms
where-- the platform we have is
called recipe
exchange, where all
the dishes within the
restaurants are featured.
It allows all the chefs
to kind of understand
what's going on in
all the restaurants,
as well it's a training tool for
the front of house employees,
and the back of house employees.
Goes step by step in making a
dish, ingredient by ingredient.
It's a very broad tool that
allows us to educate and train.
So that that's one of
the ways technology
has allowed us to be better.
With Instagram,
Facebook, Twitter,
all the different
social media channels,
it allows us to kind of
broadcast our message,
and amplify what's going
on in the restaurant,
and help to narrate and tell
a story of what the guest
experience is going to be
like, or what the employment
experience is going to be like.
So ultimately, whether it's
through training, hiring,
recruiting, guest education,
guest engagement, follow up
with the guests-- those
are all the different ways
in which technology helps
you become a better operator.
So at the end of the
day, a restaurant's
only open typically five to
six hours for dinner service.
It allows you to
focus that whole time
on the real engagement
of human interaction.
MICHAEL MINA: Yeah.
I mean the recipe exchange,
it was a great example,
because I think we were
talking earlier about something
that-- about the way you
have to look at technology,
the way you have
to think about what
you're trying to accomplish.
We started it 10 years ago.
We started because we realized
we are going to expand,
and we were going to build
multiple restaurants.
And in this day and
age, with the fact
that if you're not
using seasonal products
and you're not using
local products,
then you're not
really cooking, you
know, to the best
of your ability,
because it's just--
and so, if you're
going to have restaurants
all over the country,
and if I'm going to say
that I actually am involved
in the food in all
of those restaurants,
and to truly be involved with
that chef who's in Washington,
DC, I can't tell him that
the menu at Bourbon Steak
Washington, DC should be the
same as the menu at Bourbon
Steak, San Francisco,
because they just
have different products.
They have different seasons.
And so just to approve all of
the menus, with 26 restaurants,
I mean, you're talking about
hundreds of recipes a day
that come through to me.
And so just to be
able to collect--
and we basically built this, we
built recipe exchange, and it--
so every time that we do a dish,
every time that a chef does
a dish, basically runs it for
three days at the restaurant.
Runs it over a weekend.
At the end of those three
days, if they're still in love
with the dish, then
they send it to me,
and it has a photo of the
dish, the recipe of the dish,
and what dish it's going
to replace on the menu.
And then, I'll tell them
what I want changed on it
or not changed on
it, or whatever.
And then, if I approve
it, then they'll
do the costing of
the dish, and they'll
shoot a video of the dish.
And that will all go on
to this site that we have.
And so with 26 restaurants
now, and every dish, when
it comes off, gets archived.
So there's over 35,000
recipes on the site,
and it's all for the employees.
1800 employees
have access to it.
There's over 3,000 videos.
And typically if you're
involved in restaurants at all,
technology is very
hard to push on chefs.
Chefs hate it,
especially back then.
It's changed a lot
now, but it was very
hard to get it up and going.
I lost a lot of chefs, just
committing to doing it.
And then over a period of
time, we lost a lot of chefs.
But what I found,
at the end of it,
when we finally--
about five years
ago-- it got to where
it really worked.
And actually, every
restaurant used it.
And actually, we couldn't
survive without it,
because we shifted
it to where it's
where everybody was training.
And it's also where we
would collect-- even when
we were looking at numbers, we
were trying to look at numbers
and look at food
at the same time.
So if you're looking at your
sales on a lobster pot pie,
you're actually looking
at a lobster pot pie.
Even your accounting people--
we forced them to look at food,
and to try to
connect it together.
Just because-- just
to keep everybody
on that same mindset,
of what's important.
But really, what we ended up
finding was the same chefs that
couldn't keep up their site, you
would go into their kitchens,
and they were not
impeccable kitchens.
If they couldn't keep up
their site, more than likely,
they couldn't keep
up their kitchen.
And it was amazing
how true that became.
And to this day--
now it's great,
because now all the chefs
are very competitive.
So because everybody's
looking at each other's food,
so now they're really
competitive with it.
And it works really well.
JENNA TAYLOR: Huge
array of benefits,
both practical and
kind of unexpected.
PATRIC YUMUL: And
I think that speaks
to-- you touched on balance.
And as far as running
balanced restaurants,
you have to run a
balanced business.
You have to focus on of
the craft and the art
of the cuisine, as
well as making sure
that it costs out properly.
You have to make
sure that you're
focused on developing talent,
as well as retaining top talent.
And just running a
balanced business.
And you what you find
is that leadership is
kind of an indivisible whole.
You can't try to just
be great at one element
and be a truly great leader.
You have to actually try
to excel at all of them.
And when you see things
like a sick recipe exchange,
or the chef's representation
is kind of dismal,
it speaks to,
really, what's going
on throughout the whole
rest of the restaurant.
Because there's
a sickness there,
there's just not that
exuberance to be a master,
or to be a champion of all
elements of the restaurant,
so you know that there's
something funny going on.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's
interesting, it
being like an indicator of
a larger-- so you talked
a little bit about atmosphere,
and what you were trying to do,
bringing your personality.
I think that that is evident in
your partnership with the Levi
Stadium, and the 49ers, maybe.
It's obviously-- that
strikes a fun chord.
So maybe talk a little
bit about that experience.
MICHAEL MINA: Well,
you know, that again
was one of the restaurant
that we did last year.
And that was a big project.
But really, kind of what
the goal and mission was
for Levi Stadium, I
am a big 49ers fan--
have been for 20 plus years.
And so when I had
the opportunity,
it was more of a
passion project.
I said, you know,
this would be great.
PATRIC YUMUL: But the
49ers initially said, we've
got 6,000 square feet for you.
Do you think you
can do something?
Would you guys be interested?
And so we drove down
from San Francisco
to meet with the president
of the 49ers, Paraag Marathe.
And we talk them into,
no, 16,000 square feet.
JENNA TAYLOR: Quite a
bit more than 6,000.
MICHAEL MINA: And we set out
to create something that really
hadn't been done, because
as far as the restaurant,
we knew that we wanted to do
the pub and the steakhouse.
But really, the whole
driver was to create
this kind of environment,
and this tailgate party
that was just kind
of really to-- I
had always thrown
these tailgate parties.
And I had so many chefs,
when they would come to town,
or chefs from here would come.
And so everybody
would cook courses,
and this was out at Candlestick.
And literally, we would roast
whole livers of foie gras
out at the stadium.
JENNA TAYLOR: Ridiculous
tailgates at Candlestick,
always.
Right?
MICHAEL MINA: Yeah.
And so we said, we
want to do something
that's completely over the top.
And so we created the whole
idea of this tailgate party,
and inviting chefs from
different cities, whenever
we're playing those cities,
as well as just other chefs
that are friends of mine.
And then all of this
equipment that was really
geared for this party.
And so we built the largest
rotisserie-- indoor rotisserie
in the United States.
And so we roast a whole
Japanese wagu cow every game.
1,200 pound cow, every game.
We have these cranes
with these pots that
hold 600 gallons of water, with
these really special induction
burners that boil
600 gallons of water.
So we take the cranes, and drop
like 300 lobsters at a time,
or 150 crabs at a time.
It's really insane.
The event is just insane,
and it just was fun.
It just more of-- it
was just almost more
of knowing that it would work,
because it's so-- doing things
like that, just on
game days, works,
because you have this
very captivated group
of people, that
always want to do
something that's over the top.
And so we kind of knew that
we had the audience for it.
But then it was just, see
how far you can push it.
See what the limits were.
So we got through
our first season,
and it was pretty amazing.
JENNA TAYLOR: Keep
raising the bar.
PATRIC YUMUL: We're ready
for this season, though.
MICHAEL MINA: Getting
ready for next year, yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: So how far in
advance do you guys plan?
You have these imaginations--
MICHAEL MINA: As soon as
the schedule comes out.
We have to wait for the
schedule to come out
to know who we're playing.
We usually plan the teams that
we know we play every year.
So we plan those, and then we
wait to see who we're playing.
And then it just
depends on who we play,
because we do about 45
different dishes for each game,
and all in different ways.
So whether people are--
there's walking around,
there's outdoors.
So we'll bring in
people that do--
like, if we're playing
against-- like, this year,
we're playing against St. Louis.
We play every year, and so we're
bringing this guy, Michael,
from Poppy's Barbecue, which is
the best barbecue in the United
States.
And he's going to
do the outdoors,
so he'll do the smoker,
and the outdoors.
And then we'll have another--
usually a Michelin starred chef
inside.
And plus all of us, and
so there's a lot to plan.
PATRIC YUMUL: We typically try
to have some connective tissue
with the city we're
playing, so that we
can kind of tell that
story, of how they tailgate.
So there's always
kind of that San
Francisco versus whoever we're
playing, within that tailgate.
JENNA TAYLOR: Got to throw those
challenges out to your friends.
MICHAEL MINA: It's fun.
PATRIC YUMUL: Yeah.
And this year, we
have the Super Bowl.
So that'll be exciting.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
so are you thinking--
how do you even begin to
conceptualize what you're going
to do for something like that?
MICHAEL MINA: All the chefs that
are coming this year for guest
chefs, they're all going to
come back and do the Super
Bowl with us.
So we're going to do a big
one for the Super Bowl.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
I can't even imagine.
Does anybody in our
audience have questions?
Several layers of question.
But, in essence, how do
you still manage to cook?
How much do you get to cook?
How do you foster
innovation, with so many
different restaurants?
And how do you remain
really injected into it?
MICHAEL MINA: Sure, well
there's a couple different ways.
I mean, one thing that I'm
always very committed to
is, when we open a restaurant--
and my son, who's over there,
can be the first to
tell you-- I spent
three months in that kitchen.
And I spend three months
running that kitchen,
just like I was going to be
the chef of that restaurant.
So that way, whenever I--
because usually, my work day
is throughout most of the day,
I'm doing meetings, or more
of the administrative side.
But then-- then, nighttime, at 5
o'clock, before service starts,
I go to one of the kitchens.
And then, I always want to
be able to feel comfortable
in that kitchen, so I walk
in and run the kitchen,
and do what I would
do as if I was
the chef of that restaurant.
That's why I always spend
the first three months there,
and do that job.
And so that's how I stay
able to go into the kitchen,
and just be able to-- if you
were to come in for dinner,
and I'm at that restaurant,
I could cook for you.
That's how I do it.
And I try to block
everything else out,
once I'm in the kitchen.
I try to keep the phone as
away as much as possible,
and everything else.
And then, I cook a lot at home.
I set up, kind of-- we live
out in Nicasio, out in Marin.
And so we grow a lot of product.
And then we have our kitchen
right next to what we grow.
And so we do everything
from hosting,
but a lot of recipe development,
a lot of ideas we'll do there.
But to be honest
with you, it's more
about your second
question, which
is, how do you
nurture young chefs,
and how do you surround
yourself with talent?
That's really the answer to
the question, is at this point,
to really stay relevant, you
have to surround yourself
with a lot of talent.
And you have to have
very talented people.
Traveling is amazing.
It's much better to travel
in groups of two or three
really talented chefs,
so that you're constantly
really dissecting everything,
and questioning everything,
and everything else.
But also, too, I mean we are
very fortunate at this point,
because when we wanted to
open a Japanese restaurant--
I love Japanese food.
I have a good handle on it,
but I'm probably just about
enough to be dangerous.
So I partnered with an
amazing Japanese chef.
And so not only then
could I learn from him,
he can learn from us.
We can learn from him.
And then all of the
people in our company,
all of the young talented
chefs in our company,
now, besides just being able
to go on recipes exchange
and get these recipes
and techniques
that a great Japanese
chef will never show you,
they have access to all of them.
We all do.
And we can also really
benefit from each other.
And that's a big part
of it-- a big part of it
is really just being able
to-- part of this test kitchen
was for that reason.
And also, to let some of
our really talented chefs
in our company be able to say
that they want to do a pop up,
and they want to do-- they've
got an idea for a concept.
And they want to do
one of their concepts.
And they all get to
pitch Patric me on them.
And if we like them-- bless
you-- if we like them,
we'll let them do it.
But I would just say
that the answer is
probably the same to both,
as far as getting to cook,
I definitely force
the time to do it,
because that's
what I love to do.
And then as far as really being
able to motivate and build
young talent, you have
to look at each person
and say, what do they
need the most help with?
I mean, I have some chefs that
are amazing, amazing cooks.
Like, if they sit down and
cook the two of us dinner,
it's going to be the
best dinner ever.
But if they tried to cook
for 50 people at same time,
it's going to be a disaster.
So you have to understand
how to get them the skills
that they need to get to the
next step in their career.
JENNA TAYLOR: So
the question is,
with opening so
many restaurants,
how do you guard against
brand exhaustion?
MICHAEL MINA: I can
tell you, I think
that's more of a
geographic issue,
because I think that,
in the Bay Area,
we're trying very hard
right now to create--
if we're opening
more restaurants,
we're doing them with
like what we just did.
Like with Ken, where we
partnered with another chef,
or it's-- they're
different concepts,
completely different concepts.
The only two that
are the same are
the Bourbon Steak in Santa
Clara and Bourbon Steak
in San Francisco.
So if it's not a different
concept, we won't do it.
But a lot of times
we're going to cities
like-- when we go to a
city, we don't go to a city
and say, OK, we want to
build another restaurant.
We go to a city,
and say, we want
to compete at the
very highest level.
If we're going to go
to Washington, DC,
and build a restaurant,
we want to compete.
We want it to be known
as one of the best
restaurants in Washington, DC.
And so the two
markets where we have
the majority of our
restaurants are San Francisco,
because it's home, and then Las
Vegas, because it's Las Vegas.
And Las Vegas is just
so much different.
Each Casino is its own--
it's really its own city.
And just really looking
at them, they're
all kind of their own cities.
I don't know if there's an
answer to that question.
The answer is I can
tell you that we're
looking at making sure
we have the ability
to open great restaurants.
If we don't, then
we won't do it.
Whenever we get to
a period of time
where we don't have the
infrastructure to do it,
we usually take a break, and
we rebuild infrastructure.
PATRIC YUMUL: I
think, to piggyback on
that, we want to have
restaurants of consequence.
So we don't want to just loosely
open up a bunch of restaurants,
stick our name on it, and
then let them run themselves.
We're very intimately involved
in the day to day operations.
We're intimately involved in
kind of nurturing the talent,
working with the chefs, working
with the GMs, the leadership
team, the somms, the
bartenders, and making sure
that we're thoughtfully
curating the experience,
from the kitchen all
the way to the front,
where the hostess greets you,
as well as the technologies that
surround-- how to
accentuate that experience.
So we're just that kind
of going out, and putting
our name on things.
We're actually
actively pursuing being
a champion of that
restaurant, within whatever
markets it's in, and making
sure that it can be competitive,
and considered one of the best
in that city, or in that area.
So having that spirit
is one way to help fight
against exhaustion
or saturation.
Another is what we spoke
about earlier, is talent.
Is making sure that
we're constantly
trying to work with some of
the most talented individuals,
that we're constantly
challenging them.
That we're setting
the expectation
through being role models
in how we conduct ourselves
in the restaurants,
and how we kind of set
the example with the
openings, and then let
them know what the expected
pace is of the operation,
and what the expected
spirit is of the operation.
And then hold them very much
to it, while empowering them
and inspiring them to be able to
kind of innovate on their own.
It's kind of a give and take.
At first, it's a
lot of Mina Group,
kind of putting in systems
and guiding the restaurant.
And as we have a
strong relationship
with the chef and
the general manager,
they get a lot more autonomy,
and a lot more empowerment
to kind of creatively
flex their muscles.
And then pretty soon,
it's kind of their show,
with us as almost like
consiglieres, or guidance
counselors, to
help them maximize
what they're trying to achieve.
And then, again, it's by
having these unique kind
of different things, like
the Mina test kitchen,
where it's an
opportunity for people
to showcase their talents,
and to kind of think outside
of the box, and get
involved in something
that they might
never get exposed to.
JENNA TAYLOR: What is your
process for conceptualizing
a new restaurant?
How does that creatively
start for you guys?
MICHAEL MINA: Well, I mean
really the biggest piece of it
is something we're
passionate about.
I mean, we've never
really done anything
just based on looking
at it and saying,
well, we know that
this is financially
going to make a lot of sense.
PATRIC YUMUL: Almost to a fault.
JENNA TAYLOR: Like, you're
obsessed with ramen, maybe.
MICHAEL MINA: Yeah,
well we were obsessed--
he's obsessed with ramen.
JENNA TAYLOR: [INAUDIBLE]
son is obsessed with ramen.
MICHAEL MINA: But we were
obsessed with Japanese cooking.
And that's why we did Pabu.
And then Ramen Bar was
something that our partner, Ken,
wanted to do.
He had always wanted to do it,
and he had always wanted to do,
but he didn't know how to do it.
And so we said, you know,
let's do it together.
Let's help you on
how to facilitate,
how to be able to actually
feed people in that style
that he wanted to do it.
And so as far as
selecting the concept,
it's usually Patrick and myself.
We usually start to
talk about something--
a cuisine that we love.
But then we start to
really think about,
how would we create a
concept that would be ours?
It's not just about--
you go to Pabu,
it's much different
than most-- than a lot
of other Japanese
restaurants you're
going to go to in the city.
And that's what we
still want to be
able to put our own stamp on
whatever it is that we do.
And this kind of this eastern
Mediterranean-- the pop
up, we'll put our own stamp on.
But we already have
plans-- hopefully,
if the pop up goes
well-- of what
the restaurant will be like.
And that, we'll definitely
put our own stamp on.
And so, you know, if
the passion is there,
then it just always
is a better concept.
PATRIC YUMUL: The
pricing strategy
that we have, with wine,
in particular-- it varies.
It's kind of a flexible or
dynamic pricing strategy, based
on what we feel are going
to be workhorse wines,
that will help contribute
to overall cost,
as well as, then, kind
of higher end wines--
like you're talking about--
that aren't good cost leaders,
but they're good for margin.
But, you know, where
in a retail store,
you think about it
when you're going,
you're buying wine off
the shelf in the retail.
We pay those same prices that
you're getting from a retailer.
Maybe we might pay $1
or $2 less per bottle.
So if you're buying a bottle
of wine from a retailer,
you're buying it for $50.
We might be buying
it for $47, $47.50.
But you're taking it home.
We have a staff of people that
are-- we're receiving the wine,
we're properly storing the wine,
we're educated about the wine.
They're opening up, they're
paying for glassware,
paying for china,
paying for silverware.
There's a lot of
other expenses that
go into kind of that
cost factor for the wine.
With intoxicants, such
as beer and wine, liquor,
you don't have a huge
threshold for volume,
because people get
drunk, and then they
can't conduct themselves in
socially acceptable behavior.
As well as we have a
limited seat count, right?
So we're kind of narrow
in on exactly how
much throughput with
volume we can get.
So you've got to try to maximize
the profitability you're
going to have when you markup
stuff like liquor, beer,
and wine.
You know, what's funny is
people kind of hem and haw
about the prices for wine
and liquor in restaurants.
But you know, restaurants,
as a general business,
aren't profitable
businesses, especially here
in San Francisco
or the Bay Area.
It's extremely hard
to make a profit.
Our restaurants are probably
some of the top revenue
restaurants in the city,
and we constantly--
there's ebbs and flows
with how well we do,
just because of
the cost of rent,
the cost of health benefits,
the Healthy SF surcharges,
the minimal wage
that's increasing--
all these different things
that we have to cover.
And on top of it,
San Francisco's
very controlled with what
we can charge for food.
And it's very competitive,
and everybody's
hyper critical, and hyper
aware, and hyper vocal, as far
as what the pricing
structure is.
So we kind of have
handcuffs with that.
So we try to really
make most of our money
through the selling of
liquor, beer, and wine.
We do have, on all
of our wine lists,
a couple different
sections that allows
us to kind of go and find
great wines that probably,
if they were more
known, would be
through the roof with pricing.
But we try to keep
those priced under $70.
So we tend to have typically
about 50 wines on all
of our wine lists, that
are kind of these--
we call them hidden
gems, or back road wines,
that our somms, through
their travels, find out.
It's often the second label
from a well-known producer--
that type of stuff.
So we always try to add value
to the wine list with those,
as well as, in some
of the restaurants,
we'll do on one of the week,
like a Sunday or Monday,
try to do an industry
night-- but really it's
for everybody-- where all
the wines on the wine list
are half off.
So we try to kind of
augment the pricing,
and give some good value through
different types of promotions
and different types of finds.
JENNA TAYLOR: So how do
you build a culture where
it's OK to iterate quickly, fail
fast, as we say here at Google,
where that's OK?
Because that is a scary
concept, in general.
MICHAEL MINA:
Hopefully, not everybody
that works for us will see this.
But there's a handful of
people in our top level,
executive court.
And I kind of feel like
you need it, a little bit.
There's a handful of
people that will constantly
want to question--
really deeply question.
And in a way, will say, proceed
with caution, type experience.
And then, what I think is really
important for me-- personally--
I've found that myself
and Patrick, you know,
the two top people
in the company,
just are relentless with more
innovation-- more innovation,
more creativity, more-- when
the day comes that the two of us
say no, we just don't.
We'll try something.
We'll find a way
to test it safely,
I guess would probably
be what you're asking.
And for us, it's a
little bit different,
because we don't have to--
I'm sure, for your company,
when you have to
test something, you
have to test it
on so many people
to really get a sense of it.
But for us, we can run a
special in a restaurant
when it comes to food, right?
We can run different dishes,
we can try different things.
We can try things in--
where it gets really
tricky is, obviously, when
you're opening a restaurant,
you have a full concept.
And then it's--
We've had one philosophy
since the beginning,
and that's the fact that a
restaurant is better or worse,
every day, than it
was the day before.
And so today, my
restaurant in San Francisco
will be better or worse
than it was yesterday.
It's actually impossible
to stay the same.
It's 100% impossible.
If you're striving
to stay the same,
you're going to get worse.
There's no doubt.
You're going to get complacent.
The restaurant is
going to get worse.
And so innovation is
a huge part of that.
Finding that good balance
of being constantly
trying to innovate, but
really understanding
that you're trying
to take anything.
The biggest thing
that I'll say to chefs
is if you're not creating the
next signature dish, if you're
not creating the next dish that
likely we can never take off
the menu, then you're not
creating the next dish.
You shouldn't create
the next dish.
If, in your mind, you're not
going to create a signature
dish, if you're ever
going to create a filler
dish in the menu, don't bother.
Just because, don't bother
saying that, it's a salad,
so we have to have
a salad on the menu,
because it's actually not true.
You don't.
You have to obsess
over that salad,
and figure out how to create
the absolute best salad.
And then, when it gets
to full concepts, that's
when I think it gets to
be really fun for us,
because then it's, how do you
put the whole creative process
together, from the
design, to the menus,
to the style of service,
to the beverage,
[INAUDIBLE] to just the
actual heart, and soul,
and DNA of the restaurant.
And I think that
getting back to the fact
that, if you're not
constantly trying to push
and constantly
thinking about-- it's
not even just what you're doing.
It's obviously what
everybody else is doing.
If you're not in tune to
what everybody else is doing,
and you're not trying
to push to move forward,
it's pretty hard
to stay relevant.
I hope that answers
your question.
PATRIC YUMUL: You know,
my philosophy on failure
has kind of changed, because of
the new generation of leaders
that we have kind of coming
up through the ranks,
and the millennial
generation of workers.
And our role is
really to teach people
how to fail, and
to be OK with it.
Because as soon as
you're OK with failure,
you can have a lot of fun
with what you're doing.
If you're afraid
to failure, you're
afraid to make decisions, and
you're afraid to fully engage.
And, so a lot of times, I
look for opportunities--
I look for not necessarily I
know someone's going to fail,
but if they fail, it's OK.
It's not the end of the world.
It's not life or
death, but we have
to make sure that they're
learning from that.
If they make a mistake,
or there is a failure,
that they learn from it, and
that they try to figure out
how to overcome it.
And there's always a reason.
If it's whether I
didn't work hard enough,
or we didn't put enough time
into something, or it was ill
conceived, or it just was
flat out the wrong idea.
As long as they're kind
of taking that lesson
from the failure,
then they're going
to continue to kind of innovate
and be better and better.
And like I said, right now,
we've got a very young team.
So we're putting a lot
of empowerment on them,
and it's kind of fun to see them
go out and fail at some stuff.
But they're really quick to kind
of correct themselves, and pick
themselves up, and try to
figure out what they did wrong,
and how to improve from it.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
you're playing
with that concept a little bit
with the Mina test kitchen too,
right?
Shrink the field, reduce the
risk a little, let it iterate?
PATRIC YUMUL: Exactly, right.
And we can adapt
and change quickly.
JENNA TAYLOR: Very in alignment
with Google's culture.
MICHAEL MINA: And I think a lot
of it is what Patric just said,
as far as-- how passionate
is the person who's
trying to do it?
I mean, I'll have chefs that
will talk to me about a dish
that they want to do.
And I can tell in five
minutes how passionate they
are about the dish, or if it's
just because the other dish is
out of season and they
need to change something.
And the passion has
so much to do with it.
And obviously, you can't let
the passion be dangerous.
It can't be somebody
that's got all passion
and doesn't have the
knowledge to balance them out.
But I think that that's kind
of where the balance comes,
is how much passion and
how much knowledge, and how
much-- if they're
passionate, they've really
done the research, they
have the knowledge,
chances are it's a pretty
good bet to let them try.
And if they fail, they fail.
Our most creative
concept failed,
and it was something
that killed both of us.
We worked on it so hard,
and it, to this day,
was the best thing we ever did.
And it failed.
JENNA TAYLOR: Which was that?
MICHAEL MINA: It
was called Fourteen,
and it was in Los Angeles.
And so we have a lot of
theories of why it failed.
PATRIC YUMUL: The wrong
place, the wrong time.
MICHAEL MINA: Wrong
place, wrong time.
But it was truly the
best thing we ever did.
PATRIC YUMUL: It
was a lot of fun.
MICHAEL MINA: It
was a lot of fun,
and it was the hardest
thing we ever did.
And it was the most
creative thing we ever did,
and it might have-- like I said,
maybe it was the wrong place,
wrong time.
Maybe it was too creative.
But I tell you one thing--
what we learned out of that,
we've had probably 10
successes from there.
And probably the
biggest thing we
learned is, if we were athletes,
we would have pushed ourselves
to a point where
we created so much
stamina, the next restaurant
seemed so easy after that one.
JENNA TAYLOR: So if it was
really maybe wrong place,
wrong time, do you think you'll
ever bring it back to life?
A new iteration?
MICHAEL MINA: I don't know.
It's one of those things,
where I kind of feel it needed
to catch magic at that time,
because I don't know if we
could get the amount of
buy-in, and passion--
PATRIC YUMUL: It could
be a test kitchen--
on queue for the test kitchen.
JENNA TAYLOR: I don't know.
PATRIC YUMUL: You never know,
we might resurrect it there.
JENNA TAYLOR: Maybe for a 25
years of working together,
bring it back.
Oh, favorite places
to travel for food.
Wait, I need to make a list.
PATRIC YUMUL: I mean
obviously Europe is great,
because they're just so
rooted through history,
with the different
regions of Italy
have different ways to cook
pasta, or different ways
to cook pizza, for that matter.
And to understand why they
arrived at those ways,
or how they got to
those destinations.
France, Spain-- Spain right now
is extremely innovative in what
they're doing.
To go to Spain to see the
classic, traditional cooking,
all the way up to what Ferran
Adria was doing, [INAUDIBLE]
or even some of the other chefs,
like at Celler de Can Roca,
it's mind boggling how much
creativity and innovation's
coming out of that
region in the world.
But then to go hop, skip,
and a jump away to Greece,
and just be able to pick out
a piece of fish, and have it
perfectly cooked
as you're sitting
next to the water
in the Aegean sea--
that is pretty
remarkable, as well.
So, I mean, there's a lot of
different learnings to be had.
I love going to
Europe, personally.
I like going to Asia, Japan.
For me, what was great about
Japan was it's very modern,
and it's very Western.
However, it's still
very preserved.
Whereas, you go to
somewhere like Hong Kong,
it's very Western, and
not very preserved.
It feels like you
could be in Manhattan,
where when you're in Tokyo,
it feels like you're in Tokyo.
So I always like to have
that type of authenticity
as part of travel, as well.
MICHAEL MINA: Yeah, and I
think that a good rule of thumb
is the food you
love, the food you're
most passionate about
eating, is probably
going to be-- you might,
in certain ways, feel like,
oh, I love Japanese food,
but I eat so much of it
that I don't need
to go to Japan.
But when you go to Japan,
and you eat Japanese food,
you really understand
the culture
and why you love it so much.
I mean, to me, that's
what it's all about.
It's like when we went
to the Middle East.
What's there is the spices.
When you start to
see the spices--
and so you travel to different
places for different reasons.
But if you really want
to travel based on food,
I would just do it because
there's great food in Greece,
if you've only got a few trips.
Go to the places where you
absolutely love that cuisine,
and then spend the
time doing the research
before you get there to get
the right places to go see.
You'll have such an appreciation
for it when you get back.
PATRIC YUMUL: But Tokyo.
JENNA TAYLOR: And what
about closer to home?
Where's your favorite place
see to eat in the US that's
not one of yours?
MICHAEL MINA: Again, it kind
of depends on what level
you're looking to dine.
I would say in the
city, if I want
to go out to something
that's going to stimulate me,
I'll go to Cezanne.
Josh, we worked together, he
worked for me for a while.
I've always thought that
his food was amazing
when he worked with
us, and now what
he's done there is--
I'd say that's probably
my favorite in the city.
Benu is really good,
because it's interesting.
It's different.
I mean, there's so
many great restaurants
right now in San Francisco.
PATRIC YUMUL: I mean, those are
obviously three Michelin star
restaurants.
And then there's
like little places,
like Italian
Homemade on Columbus,
right on the outskirts of North
Beach, where it's a husband
and wife from Italy that are
making made from scratch,
handmade pastas, great sauces.
It's like $9-- everybody's
Italian in there.
You feel like you're Italian
when you get in there.
And it's an amazing kind
of authentic experience.
That's what's great
about San Francisco,
is you've got that range.
But I mean, this is
such a great city.
When you live
there, to just kind
of newly discover
different restaurants
and different finds that
are right under your nose.
But Los Angeles is
also a fun city,
and that's an
upcoming food scene.
Seattle, Portland-- those,
Seattle, Portland, Los Angeles
is also part of
another kind of Enigma,
as far as kind of
the staffing dilemma
we have here in San Francisco,
which could be another talk.
But those are all three
great, west coast cities
to see a lot of good,
indigenous cooking, as well
as some good global cooking.
JENNA TAYLOR: So how did
you decide to stand here one
Michael Mina--
MICHAEL MINA: Yeah,
that's a great question.
Because that's not
only a question,
it's been something
that chefs have had
to deal with for a long time.
And I have a very strong
feeling about that.
There's nothing wrong
with either one,
and that's my very
strong theory about it.
It really used to upset me when
I was-- I waited a long time.
I had Aqua for nine years before
I opened a second restaurant.
But it really upset me, when I
opened the second restaurant,
reading the press,
because I thought
it was some of the most unfair
press that I've ever seen.
And it wasn't just
me, it was every chef
that was opening a second, a
third, or a fourth restaurant,
back then.
Back in '98, 99, 2000.
That's when it kind
of started happening,
where chefs that actually
said they would never
open a second restaurant started
opening multiple restaurants.
And I think that the press and
people had really boxed chefs
in, had forced
chefs-- there's so
many chefs that I can tell
you that, unfortunately, I've
seen them work for partner with
a lawyer, a business person,
and that person became
a restaurateur--
the person that funded the
restaurant-- then started
becoming a restaurateur.
And the chef-- and it
was OK for that person
to go out and open
multiple restaurants.
But it wasn't OK for the chef
to open multiple restaurants,
and it really affected the
quality of the food here.
And I can tell you that
both ways are fine.
But the quality of the food the
United States over the last 10
years, since chefs started
really becoming restaurateurs--
and you see chefs, like Thomas
Keller, who, for a long time,
said he was just going
to have one restaurant,
has opened now
multiple restaurants.
And every one of
them is amazing.
They're amazing restaurants.
And not only are they
amazing restaurants,
the passion that's in
those kitchens allows
all these other chefs
to become amazing chefs.
So the more great
kitchens that you have,
the more great chefs
you're going to have,
the better food you're going
to have in your country.
And so I'm really--
neither way is wrong.
I chose my decision,
because I wanted
all the guys that
worked in my kitchen
to get their own kitchens.
And so I didn't
want to lose them.
I wanted them to keep growing.
And a lot of them now do
have their own kitchens,
and a lot of them
were chefs for me,
and they've gone on to
own their own restaurants,
or even own their own
restaurant companies.
But I feel like
there's nothing--
it was a situation that,
back in the late '90s,
it was a big topic.
It was a big topic
when chefs started
opening more than
one restaurant,
about how you're not
cooking at your restaurant,
and you're not doing this.
And at the end of
the day, you've
got to judge a restaurant
by what you eat.
You have to, you
have to judge it
by what you eat, what your
service is, what it is.
And so there is a
really talented team
of people back there
cooking, you're
still going to eat really
good food at that restaurant.
And hopefully, there'll just be
more great restaurants, which
I think right now, this day
and age, you just see it.
You see so many chefs now that
have multiple restaurants,
and they have great restaurants.
And I want them to keep
opening more restaurants,
because I want there to
be more great restaurants.
JENNA TAYLOR: Me too.
Amen to that.
Our time is up, I'm so sorry-
I've had such a great time
talking with you.
But thank you guys for coming.
PATRIC YUMUL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]